My next guest became a viral sensation on TikTok
for breaking into someone's home.
But it's not what you're thinking.
'Cause we're not advocating that here.
He didn't actually take anything from the house,
not even a little,
but he did leave it spotless after spending
two and a half hours cleaning it from top to bottom.
Yeah, I know this is such a wild story. Check this out.
(upbeat guitar music)
So my friend tells me that one of his coworkers
wants me to clean his apartment.
So I go there today and he tells me that there's a key
under the mat, get the key, go into the apartment,
clean the entire apartment. So he calls me and he's like,
"Yo, where are you?"
And I was like,
"Um... I'm in your living room, waiting for you to walk in.
I'm playing with your cat."
He goes, "Uh, man, I don't have a cat."
What?!
So comes to find out that I cleaned the wrong apartment,
and broke in and clean somebody's random apartment.
You're welcome?
(crowd laughs)
Please say hello to Louis Angelino!
(crowd cheers)
So, how did this happen?
So, I was off by one digit.
It was only one number. 227 instead of 277.
And I had just assumed
that I was going to the right address,
but it just so happened that there was two keys
under both of the mats,
which is insane, because what are the odds
that there's going to be two keys on the same time
in the same day, under both mats?
How did you even get into the taking care
of people's homes?
To be completely honest,
with everything that happened with COVID,
I was feeling very, like, uninspired,
and she's in the audience right now,
my best friend, Joe Durand's mom,
and my mother are in the office.
Oh, hi!
(crowd claps)
That is them. They are the ones that...
My mom, ever since I was a kid has always told me,
"Clean room, clean mind."
And Diana, who looks so lovely today,
(crowd awws)
told me she came up with the idea
to pay me like 50 bucks a week
to just to keep the apartment clean
for her and my best friend.
And it started out with that, and through doing that,
I would just, you know, I would go in there
with my Bluetooth speaker, and I'm jamming out,
and I'm dancing, and I'm swiffering,
and I'm having so much fun,
and I don't even realize that I'm cleaning.
I was at a very dark place at that time,
I didn't have a car. I didn't have a job.
I really didn't have a purpose, and they gave me that.
Thank you guys so much for giving that type of advice
and direction, and being such positive influences.
And I want to celebrate things like this in the world,
and, you know, you have this new passion
and you're going to pursue this as a career?
I would love to. That would be the dream.
All right. Well, I know that you started a GoFundMe page
to help kickstart your cleaning career,
and your giving, and your altruism,
and you're taking care of people,
and we just want to help you continue that and foster that.
So our friends at Safely are giving you
$10,000 worth of Safely cleaning products.
(crowd cheers)
Oh, my God!
And that is not only a year's worth of supplies,
but we'd love to feature you on our website
and help build your business.
(crowd cheers)
Oh, my God!
Thank you, yes.
Where do I sign?!
Where do I sign my soul to you?
You already did.
Oh, girl. Oh, my God.
(crowd laughs)
You already did.
Thank you so much.
It's really a big thing for my mental health.
And, like, that's one thing I wanted to mention,
is that I know everybody somehow, someway,
battles with something that goes on up here,
and if something is keeping a clean environment
can help somebody like me with mental health,
it can help out somebody else too. And that's just,
that's so important for me because mental health
really, finally, I think we're at a point
where it's being taken seriously.
Yeah. I think athletes talking about it
is really amazing.
Yes, yes.
Because if they're saying they struggle,
I think there's a lack of bias sometimes,
or maybe a greater openness to understanding,
that even the strongest people go through it.
But I think we also need to hear from everybody
about how important that mission is.
I mean, I see you building a whole business
that also recruits other people, like,
let's get this going, Louis.
Yeah. (laughs)
All right? Let's go.
All right. Thank you, Louis.
(crowd cheers)
Go on TheDrewBarrymoreShow.com to learn more
about Louis' amazing business,
and thank you for Safely, giving $10,000 to Louis' cause.
(upbeat music)